ERN UKRAINE. RUSSIAN TRO  MAKIN
RAINIAN TROOPS HE
TOTHE IN
KHARKI
>> RorTOHIALS IS GNGR A
TRIP TO THE FRONT LI
AT UNTILEN BY RUSSIA.
THEY HAVE CARS FULL TO AL.
DELIVER TO UKRAINIAN PENSIONERS
N THE MEAGER FUNDS TO
LITTERED
WITH MINES, OLDER
RESIDENTS HAVE ARED HE SMALL PO
.
VULN
THOPRING THE RUSSIAN OFFENSIVE,
WE WOULD COM BECAUSE NO
HELTH
BILLS ARCOUNTED OUT ONBY ONE TA
D COME FROM
NEARBY.
HEWAS DESTROYED.HIT
OF HER. THE SIN
THE HOST AND
DGED TONTO THE
SHE STAYING WITH A NEIGHBOR BUT
WORRIES WHAT WILL HAPPEN WHEN
WINTER COMES.
WHOSE SOED
I WISH IT OVER FOR ME,
WHEN THE BOM
IAMU WHERE
THISEEN PUSHED
BACKOOPS. AR IS GROWING THEY WI
TO COME BAN.ESE UKRAINIAN SOLDI
THEY M THAN
IN NUM IN WEE  THAT, THE SOLDIE
UNTIL OUREYR LAND. ATED, WE
AINIAN FCEOPPOSITION THIS ROCK
HE TTR
HIDE IT ON THE EOFS
AMERICAN ROCKEUNTHATN GIVEN IAN
THIS IS WHAT THESE TROOPS HAVE
AND THEY TELL US THERE
COMMANDERS TOD HOORDIN
RUSSIAN POSITION INSIDRA
TRUCK WITH ITS ROCKETS A HIS
DISTANCE AWAY AND TARGET
N POSIE LAUNCH RTHE
MIDDLE OAND FIRES
FOR ROCKETS IN
BLAC